just another person that seems to be
a key figure in this in the mythology of
this
is bob lazar it'd be interesting maybe
there's others you can tell me about but
um
bob who's also been on joe rogan but his
story has been
told quite a bit that he's got i i think
he
said that he witnessed some
of the work being done uh
on the spacecraft that was in
you know that was captured and so on in
order to uh
try to reverse engineer some of the
technology in terms of the propulsion so
on
what are your thoughts about his story
how it fits into the
mythology of this whole thing and the
broader europologist
ufologist community okay so regarding
balazar
with respect to his claims um
again i have no way to adjudicate
whether or not he actually you know
encountered this i do have friends who
are and the people that i know
who know his story some
know him um believe him and
they have said to me that the most
important thing
that they think he has said in fact
one of them i think made it
made a meme out of it or something like
that was basically he said
uh maybe the public you know i regret
making it public maybe the public isn't
ready for this kind of information
and basically they've they emphasized
that to me
and they emphasized it so much that they
wanted me to know
right so that is somewhat creepy to
me so i think okay this poor guy bob
lazar
so many people you know this is what
happens to people who have experiences
like this
they're questioned their reputations are
put on the line
in some instances their their
reputations are
manipulated on purpose to make them look
uncredible
to me as a scientist it's just inspiring
that it kind of gives this kind of
i'm not even thinking of it is there an
actual spacecraft
being hidden somewhere and studied and
so on i'm thinking of it like
i don't know it's a thing that gives you
a spark of a dream
you know to as a reminder that
we don't understand most of how this
world works
and then we can build technologies that
aren't here today
that will allow us to understand much
more and then it's kind of like almost
like a feeling
that it provides and it inspires and
makes you dream
that's that's the way i see the bobbles
in our story i don't necessarily people
ask me because i'm at mit people ask me
like did babazar
actually go to mit and so on i don't
know and i personally don't care
like it's uh that's not what's
interesting to me about
that story to me the myth is more
interesting
not interesting actually but inspiring
yes
because inspiring you're suggesting that
the myth inspires you to create reality
yes yeah i think that's that's true
so even if it's like not real it doesn't
matter
i mean in some sense just like you said
it does in some sense
it uh it doesn't
you